The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Hello and welcome.
So as I said last time,
the important part
of doing this class
is doing the homework.
We have a relatively
complicated new system
for how to do the homework,
so I apologize if there's
a couple of kinks in it.
I appreciate the feedback
pointing out the kinks.
We will try to fix them.
And we won't hold anybody
responsible for our kinks,
just so you know.
So the kinks include
there's two parts.
There's the tutor problems
that are automatically graded.
And if you think the tutor
didn't give you a just answer,
please just let us
know and we will
take care of it,
provided of course
that your answer is just.
And for the problems that
will be graded by a human,
we would like you to read the
solution so that you understand
what went wrong, if anything,
in your solution and perhaps
an alternative approach.
Most of the engineering
design problems
will be solvable
in multiple ways.
So, it's good for you
to see other approaches.
To encourage you
to do that, we're
asking you to identify
any errors that were
in your original submission.
So the importance of that
is that Homework One was due
yesterday at 5:00 PM.
And if you want to recoup
points that you lost,
you must submit marked up
version of the same thing
that you submitted yesterday by
Friday 5 PM, by tomorrow 5 PM.
You are welcome to mark up
a photocopy of the paper
and give us a paper mark-up.
If you do that, it's due in at
the beginning of recitation.
If you want to scan it, you
can send us a scan anytime up
to 5:00 PM.
Questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can I just
email you the scan?
DENNIS FREEMAN: No.
Enter it into the web site.
It's much easier for me.
The graders will all be
able to see it that way.
If you send the email
it's much harder.
It's easier if we have
everything in one place.
If there's a problem
with the tutor,
then send it to me by
email and we'll fix it.
Other comments or questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Do you
ever get them [INAUDIBLE]?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Yes, eventually.
Now, what hasn't been completely
worked out yet is whether what
you get back will be paper
or [? bits. ?] Because
we'll probably end up doing
all the grading via [? bits, ?]
because it's just easier
to communicate with all
the graders via [? bits. ?] So
that's not been resolved yet.
We're still going to work
out with the graders what's
the easiest way to synchronize
grading the electronic
and dealing with it.
So you will get feedback
but you won't necessarily
get paper feedback.
Other comments?
OK.
So last time, we
started to think
about how to think about
discrete time systems.
The thing you were supposed
to get out of last time
is that there's
different representations
for discrete time systems.
We're interested in all of them.
We're interested in all of
them because of the strengths
and weaknesses of each.
We looked particularly
at difference equations,
which are mathematically
precise and concise.
That's very good.
We looked at block
diagrams, that was good
because we could trace
the flow of information
through the network.
And we looked at
operator representations
and they were nice.
And we will see further
today how that's nice.
They are nice
because they allow us
to think about a system in
terms of polynomial mathematics.
So what I want to
do today primarily
is develop that latter theme.
Keep in mind that one of the
important features of the block
diagram was the arrow notation.
It told you what causes what.
It let you make a hardware
realization of a system.
An important point from last
time, which we just ended on
at the end of the hour,
an important point
was that when you're
thinking about the signals,
there's a higher
level abstraction that
is also important.
In addition to knowing which
is the input to the R operator
and which is the output
of the R operator,
there are some kinds
of systems that
just behave categorically
different from other kinds
of systems.
And they are indicated here.
This system has
the property that
is easy to write a recipe
for how to compute y given x.
How do you compute y given x?
Well, you take x,
copy it, invert it,
shift it to the right.
Add the copy to the
inverted shifted.
Easy to make a
recipe to do that.
It's not so easy to
make a recipe here.
Right?
So there, so if
you think about how
you would try to write that in
an operator, you could say, y.
What is y?
y is going to be x plus
a right-shift of y.
So you could say, well that's 1
minus a right-shift of y equals
x.
That's not a recipe
for computing y from x.
That's a recipe for
computing x from y.
But we don't know y.
Everybody see?
That's completely different.
And so it's that
difference that makes
this kind of a
network, this kind
of a system interesting
by comparison to that one.
And the distinguishing feature
that makes that behavior occur
is feedback.
When you have feedback,
feedback means,
for some signal
in the system, we
would say the
system has feedback
if there is some signal
somewhere whose output at time
n depends on it's same, the
output of that same signal
at a previous time.
If that's true for some
signal in the system,
then we say the
system has feedback.
The implications of
feedback are profound.
They mean, for example, that a
transient input can give rise
to a persisting output.
And we took a look at
how to think about that
in terms of the block diagrams.
You can see that if you had
even a signal that only lasts
for one sample, a signal--
a system that has this
property of feedback
could generate a response that
lasts for a very long time.
In fact, the response at time 0,
the only way that could happen
is through the
straight through path.
The only way you could get
an output at time 0, given
that the input is non-0 only
at 0 is through the straight
through path.
But then you could get
an output at time 1
if you cycled around once.
This is the idea that a
signal somewhere depends
on a prior value of itself.
And you could get a
response at time 2
by going around the loop
twice, three, 3 times, 4,
four times, et cetera.
And in general, the response
could persist forever.
That's such an
interesting behavior.
It's such a fundamental
property of these systems
that we want to
characterize systems
by thinking about them that way.
So in this particular
case, if we
think about sort of
the most simple form
that feedback
could take, this is
sort of the simplest
way you could imagine.
This is kind of
the simplest system
that you could imagine
that has feedback.
And you can see that the kinds
of responses that you can get
depend on this number p-naught.
And that p-naught characterizes
the family of responses
that you could get.
So for example, if p-naught
were a number less than 1,
you could get a decaying
geometric sequence.
If p-naught were 1 exactly,
you would get a response
that never decayed or grew.
And if p-naught were a
number bigger than 1,
then the response
could grow infinitely.
So that's a very
fundamental characteristic.
And we call that number
p-naught the pole.
OK.
Everybody's happy with that?
That's very simple-minded.
So we're going to
characterize-- so the point is,
there's a higher level
of structure in systems
that we would like to capture.
We're going to call that
higher level feedback.
It means there's a cycle
in the block diagram.
And it means that you can get
characteristically different
kinds of responses then result
when you don't have feedback.
In particular,
simple systems will
have this behavior of
a geometric sequence
characterized by a pole.
OK, just to make
sure that everybody
is with me, how many of the
following unit-sample responses
can be represented
by a single pole?
OK.
Before you answer that
question, talk to your neighbor.
Don't even bother trying to
think about the question.
Look at your neighbor.
Say hi.
And then try to
answer this question.
[AUDIENCE CHATTER]
DENNIS FREEMAN: OK.
What's the answer?
Everybody raise your hand.
Raise some number of
fingers equal to the answer
for how many of those
responses could result from--
how many of those
systems could be
represented by a single pole?
OK.
A little variety.
There's about 80% correct.
Tell me a simple one.
So tell me one
that can definitely
be represented by a pole.
OK.
Upper right.
Because it looks just like
one that I showed you before.
What's another simple
one that can definitely
be represented by a pole?
Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: Right underneath.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Underneath.
OK, so these are things that
were on the previous slide.
That should be pretty easy.
Any others?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Top left.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Top left.
Why?
There's none like that
on the other side?
AUDIENCE: Because
it's oscillating.
It's changing sides and
it's pole is negative
but because it's converging
to 0, the pole, it's magnitude
is less than 1.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So what would
be the pole for the upper left?
AUDIENCE: Some
p-naught-- so that
is like negative 1 p-naught
plus p-naught less than 0.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So can you
figure out what p-naught is?
Back in the back?
Any?
And so what's p-naught?
For the upper left, what
is the value of p-naught?
AUDIENCE: 1/2.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Minus 1/2.
OK.
Maybe.
Not really.
But yeah.
So if it were, if
p-naught were minus 1/2,
let's think about p-naught is
minus 1/2, what would that do?
OK.
If the first answer were
1, then the second one
should be minus 1/2?
What should the third one be?
Plus 1/4.
What should the next one be?
Minus 1/8.
So it doesn't quite
look like a minus 1/2.
It looks more like minus 3/4.
Yep.
Having made the
graph myself, I know
that the answer was minus 0.8.
OK.
You wouldn't necessarily
have any way of knowing that.
OK so three of them
are, how about this one?
Yes?
No?
Completely uncommitted?
My neighbor didn't know?
My partner's an idiot?
So this is geometric, isn't it?
Right?
The only thing you see there
is like 1 and 1/2 and 1/4
and stuff like that, right?
Blank stares.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So it's
not [INAUDIBLE],
so it's not diverting, so it
can't be [INAUDIBLE] unit step.
DENNIS FREEMAN: If it were
responding to the unit step,
that's absolutely true.
So if I'm thinking about
the unit-sample response,
then the unit-sample response
always looks like p-naught
to the n, n bigger
than or equal to 0.
And there's no way you
can choose a p-naught that
fits that lower left hand.
How about this one?
Same problem.
It's alternating with
the same problem.
Right?
So the only response-- so
you can't do those two.
The answer was three.
The only kinds of responses you
can model with a single pole
can be shown here.
That's not quite true.
Let me retract that slightly.
Here are some-- and I will
make this more complicated
and about two pages of notes.
Here's all the real values of
p-naught and the associated
behaviors.
In two pages, we'll get to the
complex values for p-naught.
So here's all of
that the responses
that can be associated with
a single real valued pole.
So you can get, as
somebody has already said,
you can get the idea of
diverging with alternation,
converging with alternation,
converging monotonically,
diverging monotonically.
Those are the behaviors you can
get with a single real value
pole.
OK.
That's what can happen with
a single real valued pole
but systems, there are
more complicated systems.
And when you have a
more complicated system,
you can get a more
complicated response.
And one example is shown here.
So here a system.
Here's the unit-sample response.
Is this something that can be
represented by a single pole?
No, because it doesn't fall into
one of those canonical shapes.
Right.
In fact, this response
has the property
that it grows and then decays.
But it only does the
grow and decay once,
so it's just not one
of the canonical forms.
So now there's something
different going on here
and we'd like to
understand what that is.
So we cannot represent
that by a single pole.
However, this is where the
polynomial stuff becomes useful
because I can think
about tricks I
can do with the
polynomials, which you all
learned in high school so
you all know how to do that.
That we can think about
the system in terms of,
we can think about
this complicated system
in terms of simpler systems that
can be represented by one pole.
So for example, one of
the more powerful things
you can do with a
polynomial is factor.
If you factor this polynomial--
OK, so this is a simple
representation for that right?
I can just read
that straight off.
So I can make this
representation just reading it
straight off the block diagram.
I can turn that into an operator
type representation here.
So I operate on y with
this mass to get x.
It's backwards feedback,
that's what happens.
But the second order
polynomial in R
can be factored into two
first order polynomials in R.
And not surprisingly,
that then leads
to a representation of the
more complex system in terms
of two simpler systems.
So in fact, I can write
the original system.
If I factor it, there's an
equivalent representation.
Equivalent means provided
that all the systems
start initial rest.
Initial rest means provided all
the delays started out at 0.
Putting in the
normal caveats, there
is an equivalent representation
to the complex system.
In fact, there's two
equivalent systems shown here.
Each corresponds to factoring.
And it corresponds to
doing which factor first.
So in the first
realization, it says
that generate an
intermediate signal
by thinking about the factor
that has a base of 0.7.
Then cascade that with
another system that
has a base that looks just like
a canonical first order system,
except that the base now is 0.9.
And presumably, if you
cascade those two things,
you will get an
equivalent response.
And the order didn't
make any difference.
So that's a way we can
think about the response
of a more complex system in
terms of first order responses.
So that's nice.
And that gives us then--
so we can then use the idea
of the Taylor series expansion
to think about the response
of each of those first order
systems, so we can replace the
response of the canonical first
order system with the infinite
feedforward realization--
remember from last time, the
first order feedback system can
be equivalently represented
by an infinite order
of feedforward system--
so that the unit-sample
response here.
So this system, excuse me, this
first order feedback system
can be rewritten as that
infinite order feedforward
system.
This one can be
written that way.
And then again, we can
use polynomial math
to figure out the response of
that more complicated system.
All we need to do is multiply
and then collect terms.
You all know how to
multiply polynomials,
therefore you all know how to
solve second order systems.
OK.
That's the advantage of
converting one representation,
a system representation, into
a polynomial representation
because you already know
all about polynomials.
Since you already know how
to multiply polynomials,
you already know how
to cascade systems.
The only difficulty
here is bookkeeping,
not missing a term.
So there are graphic
aids to that.
Think about the
block diagram that
would correspond to the
infinite feedforward realization
of the left part and
the infinite feedforward
realization of the right part.
So I'm thinking about this
system and that system being
represented by this
infinite system
and that infinite system.
And now just making a block
diagram realization of this
and a separate block
diagram realization of that
and cascading them to get this.
And now the
bookkeeping is trivial.
What's the only way you can
get a response if the input is
a unit-sample signal?
What's the only way you can get
a response at time n equals 0?
What's the only signal path
that generates a response of n
equals 0?
Say it louder?
AUDIENCE: The top right left.
DENNIS FREEMAN: The
only signal path
is to go through here, because
if I go through here, I
introduce a delay.
This introduces even more delay.
The only way I can
get from the input
to the output with no delay
is to go through the one
here and go through
the one here.
So that that's where
that term comes from.
The only way I can
get from the input
to the output with no delay,
no R, is through that top path.
If I want to get
one level of delay,
the only way I can do that is
to pick it up here and then not
pick it up there or vice versa.
There's more ways that
I could get two delays.
I can pick up two
delays all at once
on the left with none on
the right or vice versa
or one in each.
That's just bookkeeping, right?
It's just showing
you how you can
think about polynomial
multiplication
in different ways.
Alternatively, you could
represent it in a table.
So if you think about
multiplying these two
polynomials where I've
represented the first pole as a
in the second pole
as b, you can think
about polynomial multiplication
in a tabular form.
So you have to think about
the distributive property,
the 1 distributes
over all of these,
then the a distributes
over all, the aR
distributes over all of these
and the a-squared R-squared
distributes over all of these.
And you can represent each of
those distribution operations
by a row in the table.
And then you can see
that the only entries
with no R, with R to the
0 is along that diagonal.
And then the R terms are
here, the R-squared terms,
the R-cubed terms, et cetera.
And you can see
how that would all
sum to give you something
that's not a geometric.
OK, all those things,
just bookkeeping.
Right?
All I'm trying to say
is that there is a way
that you can think about the
second order system which
does not generate a simple
geometric sequence by thinking
about the cascade of
two systems that each
do generate a unit-sample
response that is geometric.
Nevertheless, all of
this is bookkeeping.
It's still the case that
this is a complicated shape.
And you still have to
do a fair amount of work
to figure out what that
complicated shape is.
We can use polynomials
one more time
to make it conceptually simpler.
We can do something that
we call partial fractions.
You can take the
expression that we
found for this
complicated system,
factor it just
like we did before.
But now, according to the
method of partial fractions,
you can represent the
reciprocal of a quadratic
as the sum of two terms,
each the reciprocal
of a linear function in R.
So you can always do that.
That's a property of
polynomials, right?
So what that says is that
there's an equivalent
representation for this
complicated system that
looks like this.
So backing up, so we showed
that by factoring, we
take this and turn it into this.
By partial fractions we turn
it into a sum difference.
What's the difference?
So now we think about
that difference here.
This term can be generated
by multiplying 4.5 times
a canonic first order term.
This can be generated
by multiplying minus 3.5
times a canonic
first order term.
And the response adds.
OK, well that's
completely new insight.
We've taken what looks like
a very complicated response
from a system that is
not a canonical form.
And we've turned
it into something
that does look like
several canonical forms,
just like we did
with the cascade,
but now we can see
that the answer is
the sum of two geometrics.
Everybody's with it?
So it's even better than
being able to cascade,
wherein the cascade, we have to
do some complicated bookkeeping
in order to figure
out the responses.
By thinking about it
with partial fractions,
it's the simple sum
of two simple things.
So then if you know properties
of each individual one,
life it rattles for
a long time or it
decays quickly, you can
instantly say something
about the combined response.
Does that follow?
So then this response,
which I introduced
by saying it's complicated,
it's not really complicated.
It's the sum of two geometrics.
It goes up and then down simply
because the decay constants
for the two different geometrics
are different, that's all.
The point is that this
is a very different kind
of representation.
Many things-- so
you could do a lot
by just taking a
difference equation
and just factoring it and moving
terms around and figuring out
different ways to do the
sums and so forth to try
to simplify your life.
You can do the same
with block diagrams.
You could shuffle
around the blocks
and try to make things simpler.
This idea of turning
the top system into this
is trivial to see with
polynomial manipulations
and relatively and not at
all straightforward to do
by simple block
diagram manipulations.
It follows directly from
the polynomial realization.
That's what we mean by a
more powerful representation.
It's very easy to see how we
got there if you represent
the system by a polynomial.
It's much less easy to
see how we got there
by thinking about it
as a block diagram
or as a difference equation.
OK?
Makes sense?
Because they're so important,
we would like shorthand ways
of finding poles.
As soon as you know the
poles of a system, then
you know the geometric
sequences that characterize
unit-sample response.
And for at least a
broad class of systems,
we're going to be able to
think about the combined
unit-sample responses of the
system as some weighted sum
of individual contributions.
So that makes the
idea of finding
the pose very important.
There's a very
straightforward way
that we've sort of
already alluded to.
If you had this
complicated thing
and you wanted to find the
poles, what you should do
is try to coerce it
into the canonical form.
You remember the canonic
form for a single pole system
was this sort of representation.
So you have x coming in.
Coming out as y and
feeding around that way.
That's the canonical
form for one pole system.
And that had a system
function of the form y
over x is 1 over 1
minus p-naught R.
So if you can coerce all the
parts to look like 1 over 1
minus p-naught R then according
to that, here's a pole
and there's a pole
just by canonic forms
and matching up the terms
in a canonic form, right?
That requires some sort of
graphic memory or something
graphic ability to take one form
and turn it into another form.
A simpler rule is to
say, look, just replace
all the Rs by 1 over
z, rewrite things,
and the z's turn out to be--
the values of z that are
the roots of the denominator
turn out to be the
values of the poles.
That's very
straightforward to see just
by looking at the
canonical form.
If I have the
canonical form where
I know that the pole is p-naught
and if I replaced the R by 1
over z and cleared
the fraction, I
would end up with z
over z minus p-naught.
And now if I ask what's the
poles at the bottom, what's
the roots of the bottom?
For what values of z is
the denominator equal to 0?
The answer is clearly
z equals p-naught.
It's just a trick to turn a
system function in terms of R
into a root-finding problem.
So rather than having
some program that
knows how to write
canonical forms,
you can use any root finder to
find the values of the poles.
OK so make sure
everybody is with me.
Consider the following
system, blah, blah, blah.
How many of the
following are true?
Answer looks like it ought to
be a number between 0 and 5
probably.
So talk to your
neighbor and figure out
a number between 0 and 5.
So how many of the
statements are true?
Hands?
OK, participation
is a little small,
but it's like 95, 93,
something like that percent,
except people keep changing
their number of fingers.
That makes it confusing.
OK.
How do you think
about the first one?
The unit-sample response
converges to 0, yes or no?
How do you think about it?
Yes because they all do.
True or false.
Yes.
Because there's something
special about this one.
What is special about this
one that convinces you
that that's true or false?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It has two
poles both of which
are magnitude less than 1.
DENNIS FREEMAN: It has
two poles, both of which
are magnitude less than 1.
That's precisely right.
So if we simply--
if we just do one
blackboard full of math.
So we take this.
Turn it into a polynomial form.
Turn it into a functional form.
Turn it into z's.
Everyone's happy with that?
Now you may have made
slight algebra errors
in what you were doing, but the
procedure is very easy, right?
We see that we get two poles.
Where are the poles?
Negative 1/2 and plus 1/4.
They're at the roots
of the denominator.
So is the unit-sample
response converge to 0?
It's the unit-sample response.
Unit-sample responses
are going to be
the sum of two pieces from
the partial fraction argument.
And so it will depend on
the positions of the poles.
Both poles are inside
the unit circle.
Both poles have
magnitude less than 1.
Therefore, they converge,
therefore the first one
is right.
Poles at a 1/2 and 1/4,
obviously wrong, right?
Obviously wrong, right?
There are two poles.
None of the above.
Obviously wrong.
OK.
So the answer is 2.
OK?
OK.
One more example problem.
Favorite computer
science problems
is the Fibonacci problem.
Fibonacci was thinking
about population growth
when he formulated the problem.
The idea was what if you
have a pair of rabbits that
takes one cycle to grow up.
And every cycle thereafter,
has a pair of baby rabbits.
Then the next cycle, there
is a pair of baby rabbits.
Then they grow up.
But meanwhile mom and dad
had another pair of rabbits.
But then those grow up.
And now we have more.
And then they grow up.
And you get lots of rabbits.
OK.
So that's the idea, right?
Question?
What are the poles of
the Fibonacci system?
AUDIENCE: The poles,
why isn't that--
[INAUDIBLE] to find
the poles [INAUDIBLE]
to solve for a
denominator [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Why is a
hard philosophy question.
I'm not sure I can answer
philosophy questions.
I guess I have a
PhD, maybe I can.
So it has to do with
partial fractions, right?
It's the bottom.
The bottoms are special.
And in fact, in
about a week, we'll
talk about what's the tops.
Not surprisingly, the tops
are like an inverse bottom.
What a deep insight.
So if you were to run signals
through the system backwards,
the tops look like bottoms and
the bottoms look like tops.
And there's some
really useful things
that you can derive from that.
OK what's the answer
to the question?
What are the poles in
the Fibonacci system?
Give me a number between 0 and--
1 and 5.
Raise your hand.
OK, how many are you guessed?
OK.
That's what I thought.
OK so, are there poles
in a Fibonacci system?
How would you convince
yourself there are or are not
poles in a Fibonacci system?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You can [INAUDIBLE]
as a difference equation,
so [INAUDIBLE] some
visual representation.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So you
have to start somehow.
Somehow you want to translate
that graphical problem
into a difference equation or
an R expression or something.
So one way to think about
it is a difference equation
of this form.
At time n, add some
number of rabbits
that somebody just plunked in.
That's my input.
In the example I showed by
magic, by spontaneous creation,
there was a pair of rabbits
at the beginning that
didn't obey the rules for that
were true for the rest of time.
That was x.
And y of n, also you have to
add in the two previous values.
That's kind of a rule
for the Fibonacci system.
And that has the form that
we've been talking about.
It's something that has just
adder's and delays and stuff
like that in it.
So we can write that
as a functional.
And we get a second
order denominator
so we see that
there are two poles.
And if you find the
roots by the z method,
you get these funny numbers.
And they're indeed funny.
You get the golden ratio
and you get the reciprocal
of the golden ratio,
the negative reciprocal
of the golden ratio.
So that's really bizarre
because we end up
with this whole pole, 1.618.
Tell me something about the
response of a system that
has a pole at 1.618.
AUDIENCE: It [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: Diverges.
What about this
one at minus 0.618?
AUDIENCE: Oscillate.
DENNIS FREEMAN: It oscillates.
So you take diverging
plus oscillating
and what do you get?
You get a sequence of integers.
OK.
That's pretty bizarre, right?
You take diverging
and oscillating
and you get 1, 1,
2, 3, 5, 8, 13.
That's pretty weird.
Also notice that
it doesn't behave
the way we think
about it when we
think about computer science.
There's no r-squared
growth of anything.
How many operations
is required to compute
the output at time 119?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
operations.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Depends on
what you mean by operations,
that's a good point.
So if you used a modern
laptop, how many steps
would the laptop have to take?
You have to know something
about what's inside the laptop.
These days, exponentiation
is pretty simple.
So you can think about--
so all you need
to do is raise phi
to the n an add
minus phi the minus n
and scale them and add them.
So it's a different way
of thinking about things.
That's the point.
So you can think about the
Fibonacci system as a recursion
problem like we
did in 601 or you
can think about
it as the response
to an LTI system, a linear
time invariant system
and you get this kind of a
way of thinking about things.
OK one more thing
to talk about today.
And that is, what happens
when things are complex?
You can make a terribly
small change to the system
functional.
Here all I've done is change one
sign from the Fibonacci system
and the result is complex roots.
So what's it mean to have a
system that has complex poles?
So complex poles, one of
the interesting things
about polynomial
math, complex numbers
work like any other number.
Not surprisingly then, complex
poles in a linear system
work sort of like
any other pole.
The fundamental mode
associated with any pole
is p-naught to the n.
The fundamental modes
corresponding to a complex pole
have complex values.
And that's shown here.
We can write-- so we can think
about that system polynomial
that I showed in
the previous slide.
This one.
We can write that
in a factored form.
But now, the roots
are complex numbers.
This is a complex number.
There's complex numbers
all over the place.
Who cares?
Complex numbers,
they're just numbers.
That's the nice
part about algebra.
So we don't need to
worry about that.
Other than the
modes are complex.
So if you try to plot
the mode associated
with one of the roots
and the other root,
they have real and
imaginary parts.
So here I'm showing
the real part in blue
and the imaginary part in red.
So each of the fundamental modes
has a real and imaginary part.
That's the only
complicated thing.
It's sometimes easier
to visualize the modes
on a polar plot.
And that's illustrated here.
These plots look complicated.
If you think about what they
look like in polar coordinates.
If you think about
this p-naught to the n,
but now p-naught
is complex, just
plot the number p-naught to
the n on a complex plane,
it's pretty simple.
So in this first case,
we have this pole at e
to the j and pi over 3.
Gets raised to the n-th power.
And we use trig
and we can come up
with some expression for that.
But forget trig, just remember
the Euler relationship.
And that's equivalent.
We can just use this form
to say well, if you had 0,
e to the 0 is 1.
So I'm there.
If n were 1, then it would
be e to the j pi over 3.
Well, that's there.
You go up by 60 degrees.
If n is 2, you're over here.
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
So you can visualize how
the root is behaving,
the complex root, by
looking at a complex plane.
That other root works
just the same way,
except it's negative so it
spins around the other way.
So it's convenient to watch
the behavior of complex roots
on a complex plane.
That's not too surprising.
What's slightly more
surprising is the idea
of a real system that's made
out of adders and delays
and that kind of stuff
generating a complex response.
That's a little weird.
How would that happen?
Does that mean every
time I build a delay,
I need to have an output
that is imaginary?
Or does it sort of
just squirt it out
into some orthogonal space?
Or how do you think about that?
So it's a little weird to
think about the response
of a real system
coming out complex.
And they don't.
Systems with real
value coefficients
of the type that could be
represented by a difference
equation, think about
a difference equation.
If you require that the
coefficients are real valued,
that puts a constraint on the
kinds of difference equations
that you can have.
Even though the roots
may come out complex,
if you started
with a system that
could be expressed with a
difference equation whose
coefficients were all
real, then algebra
will conspire to make the
sum of the modes be real.
It sort of all
that could happen.
Right?
So we're expecting that if it
were a physical system, if it
could be represented by
a difference equation
with real value
coefficients, how on earth
could a real valued input
generate a complex valued
output?
That doesn't make any sense.
And it doesn't happen.
And that's because
things conspire.
So this is just showing
long-winded math
for those of you who
like long-winded math.
The idea is that these
coefficients conspire
as complex numbers so that
for every integer value of n,
the answer will be real valued.
And what's showed in the bottom
is the unit-sample response
for that system.
And you can see everything's
real valued now.
So last question.
Here is the response of
a system with poles, two
poles at those complex numbers.
How do you think about
the values R and omega?
So assume that the poles are
at the polar form of the pole
location is magnitude R,
angle plus or minus j omega.
How do you think
about R and omega?
So let's say that I
plotted the response here,
can you figure out by
looking at that, what is R?
Can you estimate R?
R is approximately 1/9
0.9, approximately 0.9.
So if it were 0.9,
how's it go up?
Hmm.
So it's going around
in that circle right?
So as it's spinning around in a
circle, it's going up and down.
As it's spinning
around the circle,
the R is also spiraling in.
So the R, R to the n.
Right?
If we think about pole to the n.
The key is always pole to the n.
If we think about pole to
the n, then it's R to the n,
e to the j omega n.
The R part, R the n is
making it spiral in or spiral
out, one of those.
And the omega part is making it
go up and down and up and down.
So the R here is actually
0.97, because I made the plot
so I know what it is.
So R is 0.97.
That has to do with sort of
a gentle decay across cycles.
So you could figure
that out for example
by finding the ratio of
that height to that height.
Sort of, how much did the
decay when it came around once?
So R is 0.97, what do
you think omega is?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Around 0.5.
So what you need to think about
in omega is if you go n steps
and each advances
the angle by omega,
how long does it
take to get to 2pi?
Right?
It will go around the circle
once when the radiant angle,
when the angle goes
increments by 2 pi.
Every time, every step, the
angle is incremented by omega.
How many steps does it
take to get to 2 pi?
That takes-- if I started
here and went to there,
I get 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
Takes about 12.
So 12 omega is 2 pi.
And so omega is approximately,
well it's exactly,
well, no it's
approximately-- this should
be approximately 2 pi over 12.
6 over 12 by
blackboard math is 1/2.
OK.
OK there's one more slide.
But that will turn out to be a
good question for you to review
as preparation for the exam.